[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en Francia 24
Bienvenidos a África 7 días estos son
los titulares en el capitán
ibrahimtradore fue oficialmente nombrado
jefe de estado entre los retos que
tendrá que abordar están la lucha contra
el terrorismo y la inseguridad
alimentaria
amnistía internacional publicó uniforme
sobre el alcance de la violencia sexual
en línea con actriz donde el acceso a la
justicia es una carrera de obstáculos
para las víctimas conversamos con
investigador en amicia internacional
quien nos dio más detalles sobre el
informe y los llevamos a Costa de Marfil
donde la trayectoria de Ruth campeona
mundial de taekwondo está siendo emulada
por muchos en este país el taekwondo se
ha convertido en el segundo deporte
después del fútbol
comenzamos en burkina faso tras el golpe
de estado que derrocó al Coronel damiba
el capitán Ibrahim traoré fue nombrado
presidente los retos que le esperan son
numerosos desde finales de 2015 el
estado de burkina faso ha perdido el
control del 40% de su territorio y ha
sido objeto de múltiples ataques
terroristas uno de los acontecimientos
que desencadenó este último golpe fue
precisamente un atentado el de la ciudad
de gaskin de veamos
en el norte de burkina el 26 de
septiembre un convoy de decenas de
camiones cargados de alimentos fue
objeto de un ataque yihadista a gran
escala este conductor estaba al volante
de su vehículo cuando sonaron los
disparos Tuve miedo pero luego se me
pasó pero tuve miedo porque estaban mis
compañeros y a los que ya no podía
encontrar y otros que murieron el convoy
había salido de wagadugo con destino a
givo una de las principales ciudades del
Norte del país sometida el bloqueo por
parte de los yihadistas allí unas
300.000 personas la mayoría desplazadas
viven bajo la presión de los grupos
armados desde hace casi dos años para
evitar la hambruna que amenaza a la
ciudad donde casi no entran ni salen
alimentos el ejército se ha comprometido
a acompañar a los convoyes de
suministros
para el convoy Todo cambió en unos
segundos
en un momento dado vimos que los
soldados estaban corriendo como locos
Cuando se suponía que debían protegernos
protegidos por los militares Pero ellos
mismos huyeron bueno
[Música]
la vida de 37 víctimas entre ellas 27
soldados 70 camioneros siguen
desaparecidos según algunos analistas el
asunto precipitado la caída del teniente
coronel Paul Henry damiba que había
prometido durante su golpe de estado de
enero recuperar el control sobre los
yihadistas
el lenguaje que utilizaba el partido en
el poder en la época de damiba era que
el ejército estaba creciendo en fuerza y
que todo estaba bien
y que eran capaces de abastecer las
zonas que estaban rodeadas la gente de
los pueblos se lo creyó Así que este
atentado fue detonante despertó a la
gente que se dio cuenta de que en
realidad todo lo que se había dicho
desde el principio era mentira no era la
verdad
pocos días después del atentado un golpe
militar El quinto en dos años en la
región derrocó el poder vigente en
wagabugú y capitán Ibrahim traoré lo
justificó en parte por el continuo
deterioro de la seguridad
de los delitos sexuales en este país ha
sido expuesta en un informe de la ong
amnistía internacional el informe fue
publicado en vísperas de un juicio
histórico el de la masacre del 28 de
septiembre de 2009 en la que soldados y
policías mataron a más de 150
manifestantes y violaron a 109 mujeres
durante una concentración de la
oposición en un estadio de conakry para
hablar de ello nos acompaña fabia ofnair
investigador de la oficina de occidental
de amnistía internacional
Fabián Gracias por aceptar responder a
nuestras preguntas en primer lugar me
gustaría preguntarle por qué Guinea en
particular está tan afectada por este
tipo de violencia
habitación Buenas noches gracias por la
invitación Lo que quiero decir en primer
lugar es que no hemos elegido
específicamente trabajar sobre Guinea en
este informe porque en este país hay más
violencias que en otros;
escribimos informes sobre algunos de los
países de la región que cubrimos
elegimos hacer un informe sobre Guinea
porque vimos por un lado que había un
compromiso real por parte de las
autoridades sobre el tema y sobre todo
por parte de la sociedad civil y de las
organizaciones en particular con dos
momentos clave en 2015 el llamado caso
de tancítauré un artista que fue acusado
de agresión sexual y en 2020 la muerte
de una joven llamada maxila que fue
violada varias veces en una clínica
clandestina en conakry antes de morir a
causa de sus heridas tras ser evacuada
atunes
se han producido verdaderas
movilizaciones en los últimos 10 años
sobre la cuestión de la violencia y las
violaciones y por eso hemos querido
seguir los pasos de los permisos
adquiridos por las autoridades a raíz de
estas movilizaciones y no es
necesariamente porque haya más
violaciones en línea que en otros
lugares hay muchas violaciones en África
occidental pero también en Europa y
Estados Unidos Estados Unidos
pero algo está pasando en este país en
torno a las violaciones y la inclinación
está alcanzando un nivel bastante alto
la gota que colmó el vaso como han dicho
algunas organizaciones
y para terminar con su Pregunta guineas
también el motivo porque hay que situar
esta violencia sexual y estas
violaciones en el contexto más general
de la impunidad estamos en un país en el
que Hay muy poca justicia para este tipo
de crímenes tenemos víctimas que llevan
exigiendo justicia desde la época del
presidente secoutoré desde el presidente
lanzana con t y obviamente el juicio del
28 de septiembre 13 años después de los
hechos da una idea de la espera que
puede existir en este país para obtener
justicia
el informe ofrece una visión general de
la situación y formula recomendaciones
pero no sugiere soluciones para combatir
la estigmatización de las víctimas que
se puede hacer para combatirla
es muy difícil luchar contra el
funcionamiento de la sociedad y contra
lo que las directrices de La Unión
africana para la lucha contra la
violencia en África llaman la
perpetuación de los estereotipos en
particular los patriarcales
hay cosas que se han hecho está el
código civil que fue modificado en 2016
por ejemplo en Guinea desde la
modificación de este código civil ya no
se considera necesariamente al hombre
como cabeza de familia por lo que ha
habido una evolución que es
principalmente legislativa pero en un
país como Guinea existe una brecha
difícil de llenar entre los textos y su
aplicación
Pero esto es algo que afecta a la
sociedad en general en el informe
destacamos el hecho de que estos
estereotipos patriarcales Fueron
transmitidos por artistas a veces
incluso por autoridades su perfectos que
justifican a medias ciertas violaciones
por el hecho según ellos de que algunas
mujeres no se vistieran adecuadamente es
un trabajo que debe hacer toda la
sociedad a través de los periodistas
profesores y por eso nos reunimos
también con el Ministerio de Educación
[Música]
porque una de las obligaciones
internacionales en materia de lucha
contra la violación sexual es tener
programas y módulos de educación sexual
y esto no es así por el momento en
Guinea y algunas de las personas con las
que hablamos algunos grupos de mujeres
que estaban un poco decepcionados nos
dijeron que uno debemos apostar por las
personas mayores Porque será demasiado
difícil cambiar sus mentes sus opiniones
su mentalidad pero debemos apostar por
las generaciones futuras por los niños
por tanto esto implica obviamente la
educación sexual pero también una
educación más general sobre los derechos
de la mujer en las escuelas
Gracias por estas aclaraciones
es marfilenia se llama Ruth y es
campeona mundial de taekwondo su éxito
inspira a muchos es por eso que en 10
años el número de practicantes de este
deporte se ha triplicado actualmente el
taekwondo es el segundo deporte en Costa
de Marfil después del fútbol
[Música]
estos niños con kimonos están esperando
a su ídolo
27 años acaba de ganar la medalla de oro
en el mundial 2022 de taekwondo en París
una recompensa que quiere compartir con
su Club de la infancia
Para mí es importante compartirlo porque
ahora soy una figura emblemática en mi
país hay muchos jóvenes que se fijan en
mí y que quieren ser como yo así que es
importante compartir mi experiencia para
inspirarles a conseguir sus sueños
todos sueñan conseguir sus pasos desde
muy jóvenes compiten en combates y
entrenan bajo la atenta mirada del
maestro George Él es quien lleva Ruth al
máximo nivel por menos de 10 dólares
estos pequeños tecundistas aprenden a
ser ágiles y rápidos frente al
adversario George hace hincapié el
respeto y los buenos modales en el
taekwondo hay una parte deportiva y otra
educativa la educación cívica en las
teorías que hacemos con los niños hay
asignaturas teóricas y prácticas cuando
los evaluamos por lo que primero que
todo damos una educación a estos niños
un deporte que atrae a los más jóvenes
pero también a los mayores es en este
templo uno de los más grandes de África
situado en el corazón de abellán donde a
Ruth Se entrena cuando Vuelve a casa hoy
comparte
presidente de la Federación de taekwondo
de Costa de Marfil y alcalde de cocody
inició en el taekwondo cuando estaba en
el ejército una práctica obligatoria
para todos los soldados en parte Esto es
lo que ha hecho que este deporte sea tan
popular para él esta disciplina que
cuenta con más de 50.000 miembros es una
ventaja para el desarrollo de Costa de
Marfil ha tenido un efecto positivo en
la población ha permitido a la gente
reenfocarse a algunas personas que lo
hacían para poder hacer otra cosa sean
reenfocado se han centrado Pueden decir
que estaban estudiando o enseñando se
han tranquilizado y orientado y creo que
es beneficioso este arte Marcial en 10
años se ha triplicado y con los Juegos
Olímpicos de 2024 los marfileños esperan
tener aún más medallas
dejamos el continente para hablar de su
diáspora andreísa Anaya Espinosa es
comunicadora social afrocolombiana y ha
sido nombrada como una de las personas
menores de 40 años más influyentes de la
diáspora africana por su trabajo de
fortalecimiento de los procesos sociales
y culturales de la población
afrocolombiana andreísa Espinosa fue
nominada por la organización most
influencer people of african decent
hablamos con ella sobre su galardón el
premio reconoce justamente a nivel
global que están haciendo estas nuevas
generaciones o que estamos las haciendas
nuevas generaciones afros a nivel global
y por supuesto creo que lo más
importante no sólo para mí sino para las
nuevas generaciones es poder estar
mostrando nuevas formas de contar los
territorios como donde me encuentro en
verrugas sucre donde soy originaria
poder contar que hay unas agendas más
allá de la violencia Más allá de los
conflictos más allá digamos de las
necesidades que generalmente se nos
genera como estereotipos sin duda el
premio mi fa lo que hace es digamos
encontrar esos liderazgos a nivel global
de los diferentes países africanos y de
los diferentes países de las Américas y
de Europa y que permite por supuesto
fortalecer y una red de liderazgos a
nivel global pues ahorita estamos
justamente trabajando con el proyecto o
el comité científico del proyecto de la
ruta de las personas esclavizadas donde
soy miembro por Colombia ante la UNESCO
y ese es uno de los elementos más
fundamentales que estamos promoviendo
como una instancia que somos para hacer
recomendaciones a los Estados y uno de
los elementos claves es decir a los
Estados implementar acciones agendas
estrategias planes y programas que
permiten que que conlleven la el
relacionamiento de la diáspora africana
a partir de la creación de nuevas y
otras narrativas ya sea desde la
comunicación desde la política desde la
cultura
es todo por hoy en África siete días
pero quédense con nosotros la actualidad
internacional continúa en francés 24 y
Francia
[Música]